what practices or processes if any do
you have for keeping up with your
Japanese Spanish and other languages all
right I do have some approaches here so
number one is something that's become
much easier in the last handful of years
and that is movies watch movies not only
watch say for instance movies in
Japanese so Japanese movies with English
subtitles watch English language movies
with Japanese subtitles and ditto for
Spanish right so watch English language
movies you know well ideally right could
be something you've seen a 100 times
like die hard or whatever doesn't really
matter with Spanish subtitles and
then conversely watch Spanish language
movies with English subtitles preferably
that's
something that is say a series or a
television show I just find there's a
little bit more Grist for the- Mill and
you can get used to the speech patterns
of various
protagonists and actors within a given
Series so I've done that with Spanish
multiple
times another approach is linking them
together so linking languages together
and what I mean by that is if for
instance you have learned in my case
Japanese first when I wanted to
learn German I bought both Japanese
language versions of One Piece which is
a very famous manga very famous comic
book I bought German language versions
of the same one piece comic book which
is a global phenomenon many people know
it now but certainly back in
2005 this would have been less
common in German and then later in
Spanish so I could read the same series
and if I'm reading the German and I
don't understand a section rather than
going to an an English English German
dictionary or a German English
dictionary I'm going back to the
Japanese and I'm using the Japanese to
learn the meaning of the German and by
doing that I'm reviewing my Japanese
while acquiring the German and then
later for instance when I did Spanish I
used the
German language version of One Piece as
my safety net for the Spanish language
version of one piece so I'm reading it
in Spanish if I don't understand
something I'm not going to English I'm
not going to Japanese I'm going to my
most recent language which is going to
be in that case German if that makes any
sense and what's beautiful about these
comic books is they are laid out Page by
Page Pain by
pain typically in exactly the same way
uh so the dialogue should map really
cleanly and another benefit which I just
alluded to for the comic books is that
they are almost entirely dialogue rather
than
Exposition dense Pros that is very
literary in nature almost all of it is
dialogue and granted they might be
talking about Pirates or something else
that's not going to fall into your daily
conversation all the time but a lot of
it will and certainly the grammar
will